many of us are only venturing out of the
house to buy food and other necessities
but there's one place where people are
encouraged to go outside for fresh air
and exercise many are doing just that
while also finding ways to keep their
distance from others christina Ruffini
has the story from Washington they
suited up in an empty lot and made their
way down the riverbank just as dawn was
breaking their boats hit the water the
same time as the Sun it's a great time
to paddle so it's super pretty I'm Sun
rising everything's kind of fresh my
favorite thing about being on the water
is that it makes it feel like nothing's
wrong and it is you know just as
beneficial mentally as it is physically
Erin massara
Laura Duran and Joe pepper drove an hour
outside Washington to find this peaceful
part of the Potomac the early hour lets
them fight the rapids without other
kayakers around between the river flow
and just the size of the boats you're
gonna maintain this as plus if you're
too close to me I'm gonna probably eat
you with the paddle and no one that's a
really aggressive method of social
distancing it's effective you know I've
got to meet them CDC guidelines
desperate to escape coronavirus lockdown
Americans are heading outside to take a
break a breath or just a moment to
themselves
the crowds can make it hard to social
distance and not everyone understands
the need for personal space which is why
Kristen Shanna key hits his track early
really early I work at a clinic at 7:30
in the morning so in order to avoid the
crowds and still get my workout and I go
before instead of after she says
sticking to a routine helps her cope
with Kumud related stress it's one of
the few things that we still can do I
can still go for a run in my favorite
places so it's meant a lot to me with
their favorite places to Pat's during
the day
friends Joby Jones and Holbrooke Hayes
have been waiting until after dark to
escape their apartments riding bikes
around DC and the deserted National Mall
it's nice riding bikes around the city
even when something like this isn't
happening
it's a great way to see the city it's a
great way to see the monuments at night
the first time we ever did this was it
was the first time things felt peaceful
and didn't feel stressful and those off
our outings can have other unexpected
perks the first time I was ever
perceived the sky at night in the city
it was nice it was therapeutic for sure
of course it's always been there the sky
above the city it just took a pandemic
to see the stars
for CBS this morning Saturday Christina
Ruffini Washington finding the bright
spots